this is so cool man I wish wish my
grandpa could see this man he uh I I I
always wanted to bring him here to visit
he know he knew how much I love DC and
he he he loved Maryland was like his
favorite state which no no which you
know is is a valid response unless
you've been to Baltimore because
dude the [__] is going on in Baltimore
dude bro Maryland as a state cannot pick
a tone dog just pick one it's so
beautiful and so ratchet for no
reason can y'all just pick a tone man
all of Maryland y'all will drive to the
beach with your top down and then go to
Baltimore and lock all your doors dude
like you don't no middle ground ever man
I've only been to Baltimore one time I
ate lunch there and the hostess who like
seats you at the restaurant had a black
eye a full black and it wasn't like what
happened it was pretty obvious what
happened and we couldn't get over the
fact that we're like this is the face of
the company like this is this is who you
have greeting people and my boy who I
was with was like yeah I feel bad for
her man I feel like they should put her
in the kitchen or something where nobody
nobody has to see her face you know and
I was like yeah but I feel like if she
could cook she wouldn't have that black
eye
so just testing the water seeing if
y'all are going to be fun or not just
wanted to see just wanted to see
I figured we start the show with
domestic violence the rest of the show
should
be should be pretty smooth sailing after
that